[Music]
all right guys the Amaze we are here
backstage in the press room how is this
performance going to top all other fifth
harmony performance what do we got first
of all to be amazed so there's that and
we're gonna bring so many different
elements and surprises and so much
energy it's really gonna be such a
moment people are gonna be gagging its
harmony teasing exclusive VMA details to
ET the girls will be performing their
hit song down what about the costumes
are we matching are we going it's gonna
be amazing
what we're taking home a moon man means
you well I like just we know I mean
thankfully like whatever universe is
going on but it for real like anytime
you win an award but especially the
views there's so micronic is just like a
humbling experience it's just like wow
we worked so hard for this and it's so
gratifying in like validating for
somebody to be like hey here's a moon
man like if this week couldn't get any
cooler
boys have an album coming out Friday you
co-wrote so much of it what's the
advantage to writing your own songs and
then recording them honestly yeah being
able to connect with the music
and just recognizing that you actually
believe in what you're doing and I feel
like we almost got we got our power back
and we learned to love music again just
because you know it reflects our voices
and we say everything that we want to be
able to say and we know how we want it
to sound and we know that in 10 years
they don't mean what it means now to us
you know it's still special
[Music]
you